aren't supposed to be mean to people
we're not supposed to call people names
and whack fingers so we express worry
over them instead don't don't show me
what you're showing me what for
expressing worry you're like 50 pounds
overweight you should be worried oh my
gosh oh my gosh what up guys welcome to
the dust pearly things YouTube channel
and welcome to my reaction series uh
today I've been going through all of my
favorite conservative media people of
like all time and I thought about
Stephen Crowder putting him in my top
five like if I had to have a Mount
Rushmore of conservative media he would
be on it potentially I've been going
back and forth so we are going to react
to one of his most viewed videos uh I
think he's like crashing some social
justice conference or something I don't
know but before I start guys like the
videos that is the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out these live
streams let's get started roll the clip
foreign
[Music]
with a social justice activism panels at
South by Southwest not gay Jared and I
attended the my body is not safe for
work fat Pride breakout session to ask a
few simple oh my gosh can we look up to
see guys if there are any of these
please leave them in the comments police
send me them on Instagram just pearly
things one send it because I need to go
to these body positive things accurate
if mildly triggering questions but
before that it's important that you see
the narrative they were using to set the
stage concerned trolling I think is a
big thing in general in this space and
it's like are you actually concerned do
you actually compare care at all about
my well-being
um because if you did maybe you wouldn't
be harassing me because it's not great
for my mental health it's the gateway to
basically just saying I don't like you I
don't like what I'm seeing
um but I don't like what I'm seeing so
you know drop a few look it I don't even
mind big people okay I'm really don't
what I what irritates me is delusional
big people like big people with the goal
of losing weight and not succeeding okay
fine but the big people that are I am
fine as is I have no changes to make
everyone else who deal with my poor
decisions that is where I have an issue
you know that we aren't supposed to be
mean to people we that's another very
popular idea and a good one that we're
not supposed to bully we're not supposed
to call people names and whack fingers
so we express worry over them instead
but it all amounts to the same it almost
the same as don't don't show me what
you're showing me but what for
expressing worry you're like 50 pounds
overweight you should be worried oh my
gosh for me it really is about just
reclaiming it and saying like I'm fat
and the fact that you still find me
attractive is your problem if you see a
fat girl online who hates herself and is
in sweatpants and talking about how
miserable she is in crying people are
much more likely to be supportive of her
diet
um and her exercise eyes but when you're
confident and you're saying I love
myself but here I'm in a bikini and I'm
okay when you're throwing your rolls in
my face look it I'm also not supportive
of only fans workers throwing their
sexuality in my face what they do on
their only fans fine I mean I don't like
it but fine that's private but when
you're putting graphic images on sites
that children can see I got a bit of an
issue sorry and a lot of times these fat
chicks want to put their roles up and
have no backlash for putting sexual
looking content on the internet
immediately people have you know really
strong feelings about that pause so wait
you mean to say that When You're
vulnerable and upset people are kind and
consoling and willing to offer
supportive advice but when you're
arrogant and bombastic people are put
off they've got some nerve on them I I'm
also I don't know voluptuous for sure
can you look up on your phone just look
up fat acceptance events near me please
and that's okay are you testing someone
which I think is important earlier about
health care affordable access to
healthcare meeting you know uh I think
you said a human right so in that sense
with the fact that people who are
overweight like myself or obese are
three to seven times more likely to
develop diabetes or cost 256 billion
dollars more per year
um isn't that a concern of the taxpayer
and don't they have a right to have an
opinion and just like smoking encourage
healthier body styles if the taxpayer is
involved in this decision
funny I mean this is like obviously an
incredibly nuanced conversation I think
it starts a lot younger and a lot
earlier than by the time anyone has
developed some of those issues or gained
the weight I think you can't talk about
that without also talking about the food
industry and corn subsidies and access
to health care for prenatal care and
look it I am sympathetic they have
messed up our food they've messed up our
water I understand but at the end of the
day your health is your own problem your
health your health is your
responsibility all right intervention
and education you can't just talk about
that people have diabetes and have more
likelihood to end up with diseases that
cost the tax care without talking about
the entire approach to body's health or
access to Food Water flame chicken soils
we have clean water housing for three
years
oh so Flint Michigan's tap water made
you fat well that explains it if we see
a statistical risk pool do we also agree
that like insurance companies should
have the right to discriminate in that
sense
none of us would agree that it's okay to
discriminate against fat bodies up here
but if you are you know excluding people
or penalizing people based on size you
are not just discriminating based on
says you're also discriminating based on
you know a number of things including
racial and ethnic backgrounds for
example what cause what she just
insinuate that black people are fat
none of us have an issue with promoting
Healthy Lifestyles I think in K in
arcade actually is a really big part of
of our identities and Brantley Nicolette
and I talk a lot about uh we're both
gluten-free Etc because of our
conditions oh it's the gluten okay guys
I'm sorry I just hate excuses oh my gosh
look it is our food messed up yes is our
is our water messed up yes but is that
an excuse no because we can all point to
somebody that's in great shape and very
healthy despite all of these risk
factors all right that's the ticket and
that being said I am very much someone
who wants to promote living a healthy
and healthy ways but I don't equate that
necessarily to a certain size 700 chance
more likelihood of someone you know
developing heart disease or diabetes
should we promote that you know for kids
who are coming up we agreed that all
right guys in the chat your kid being
fat child abuse I think yes I really
think it is because you're teaching
these kids horrible habits that will
last the rest of their lives and guys
that's the thing half of the time making
bad decisions doesn't just affect you it
affects everybody around you like being
fat now your kids have to deal with the
habits you pass on to them being a [__]
now your kids are going to be bit like
or you die alone and just you know which
a lot of fat chicks probably will to be
honest we should not promote to lose
weight we should promote healthy
behaviors there's a much larger issue of
the way we um ties bodies the way
they're approached in the medical and
health industry the way that the medical
industrial complex is structured in
general of course not it must have been
the gluten and what have you of course
that statement begs the question as to
just how the medical industrial complex
managed to so effectively Target
exclusively these women but there wasn't
enough time to get into that so not gay
Jared had a question of his own
great
um question for you uh I just you talked
about some studies and I'm sure there's
probably a lot of studies out there but
there's been several studies that show
that
um when holding men uh versus this one
how to New South Wales in Sydney
the study involved almost 60 60 000
volunteers rating almost 1 000
variations of the female figure and What
discovery was was that
um more attractive ones are almost
always tall uh and thinner rather than
large and curvy
um question for you is is it possible
that within uh fighting the idea of body
shaming there's a there's actually a
possibility of shaming natural male
biology that prefers uh thinner leaner
um healthier women
I think it's what about that survey said
it's natural male biology not societal
oh my gosh oh my gosh I'm sorry men are
not this delusional I mean some are I'm
not gonna I've met I've met my fair
share adult I could do a whole rant on
delusional man okay I really could I
really could uh but delusional women are
only the ones confident enough to put on
a whole presentation whole show and say
that men because of society don't like
fat women
I think a lot of our preferences are
socialized are they asking babies
were they asking baby oh when you go to
other cultures and ask their preferences
like our attraction is so much
specialized of course it is
um but I found that this is actually
true across generationally the idea that
people just are men just biologically
are start to come out of the womb
attracted to thin tall women it's like
ridiculous and also I am literally
offended by the two middle Commons I
mean it's not surprised
so yeah This Woman's questions
[Music]
do you see like it they just called they
said oh something about the white male
having this opinion back in 2017 that
was so common they were just discredit a
guy's opinion just because he was white
and a guy it was so common back then I
did to whoever you're attracted to
there's nothing wrong with that if a
person is not attracted to me because my
body is larger I don't care there's a
million of other people who are
um in fact I wished you were mad because
you feel shade
you're liking thin women that's not the
problem we don't care but yeah I think
it's okay that is wrong to not find
certain body types
[Music]
attention to like
and not Surprises with the maximum
triggering occurring we had to get the
hell out of there but as CIS white males
we wanted to ensure that we weren't
wrong with our information so we decided
to sit down with a local doctor Dr Mike
Simpson to get his professional opinion
also side note we did have one other
cameraman with us at that panel but he
got eaten
wow
this has got to put Crowder in my top
five he's Mount Rushmore okay let me
know who else in the comment is in the
Mount Rushmore of conservative media so
now you're telling me Oh Tucker Carl's
Tucker Carlson wasn't my generation
though that's like the last Mount
Rushmore but I am obligated to do by the
oath that I took and what the government
actually has on a checklist that I must
discuss with you the moment you get on
the scale of my emergency room and
you're over a certain basic metabolic
index that triggers a question on the
electronic medical record did you
discuss weight control with this patient
just like if you say I'm a smoker did
you discuss smoking cessation so now
you're telling me that I am trolling you
because I'm doing that
yeah oh and by the way by the way
because of uh the Affordable Care Act
and many other governmental restrictions
if I don't ask you that question I don't
get to bill for full price for that
chart now I don't care I'm not in this
for the money I am in it because I care
about People's Health but don't accuse
me of trolling when I'm telling you you
are going to die you're gonna this guy
really needs to check his MD privilege
again why does this matter because just
like the anti-free speech panel we
covered earlier this week this entire
fat Pride movement is centered around
controlling what people are allowed and
are not allowed to say when you
categorize everything as hate speech
including medically correct assessments
designed to keep you alive
you eliminate the ability for any
conversation to take place as you see
here even with issues that are literally
life and death but
shh don't tell anyone that's just
concern trolling
top five King who's your favorite today
what's your favorite video so far I
would say um what's his name Ben yeah
Ben yeah he he is goaded
um let me know what you guys think
though in the comments
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel ring the
notification Bell who are your top five
conservative Mount Rushmore of
conservatism and I also feel like we
might need different mount rushmore's
for different eras but this is you know
when I was like 18 16 when I was
watching this stuff so let me know what
you guys think in the comments like the
video on your way out and I'll talk to
you next time